[MUSIC]
Hi, I'm Ken Shotts, I'm a professor of
political economy at the Stanford GSB.
>> My name is Neil Malhotra,
I'm also a professor of political
economy at the Stanford GSB.
And Ken and I would like to share some key
class takeaways from the course we teach,
Leading With Values, which is also
the title of our forthcoming book
[MUSIC]
When people disagree about ethical
issues in the workplace or
in their organizations, sometimes these
disagreements are about facts and
sometimes they're about values.
Now when we disagree over facts,
these are not easy things to resolve, but
they can be addressed if people
can bring evidence to the table.
This is not the case with values.
No amount of evidence is going to convince
people that their values are right or
wrong.
So where do these values come from?
Well, psychologists have shown that
they come from deep seated moral
intuitions that lie in our gut, and
they often have a cultural basis.
What does this mean for
leading with values?
Well, when people disagree about
ethical issues in the workplace,
it's not because some people are moral and
some are immoral,
is that they're bringing different core
values based considerations to the table.
[MUSIC]
People around you, specifically
those who are critical of you and
your company, oftentimes are motivated
by key moral intuitions.
So it's not helpful to just dismiss their
concerns out of hand by saying that
they're self-interested or
motivated by money.
It's oftentimes important to respect
the fact that they have moral intuitions,
even if they're different from your own.
We like to oftentimes think of
ourselves as very rational and
everybody else as driven by emotion,
but this isn't the case.
Even when we're making very rigorous,
highly structured analytical arguments,
the roots of those arguments
are in our gut intuitions.
And that self-awareness is
important to be reflective and
to be skeptical of yourself.
[MUSIC]
If you want to communicate with others,
persuade them, and
manage disagreements in your organization,
it's oftentimes important
not to use your own moral intuitions
as the basis of framing your argument.
But to be empathetic, and to see what
are other people's moral intuitions, and
construct your arguments
about how they see the world,
not necessarily just
how you see the world.
[MUSIC]
>> Our students talk a lot about
their sense of purpose, and
their personal values, and
their personal ethical commitments.
We also see leaders of companies talking
about how they want all of their employees
to do the right thing and
to behave in ways that are aligned
with the company's values.
And at a societal level, we see many
companies, especially nowadays, talking
about their commitments to improving
society in a whole lot of different ways.
All of these good
intentions are wonderful.
However, as wonderful as good intentions
are, good institutions are even better.
So what do we mean by good institutions?
We mean setting up incentives, rules,
and norms that promote good behavior.
So this is most obvious within a company.
When a leader of a company says, we expect
our employees to do the right thing,
here's our values as a company,
that's good intentions.
Good institutions is setting up incentives
and rules and norms within the company so
that people are rewarded for doing things
that are aligned with that good behavior.
And are not rewarded for doing things
that are out of step with those values.
[MUSIC]
And
if we want companies to do
the right thing for society,
when push comes to shove, we need to
have government regulations, rules, and
laws that incentivize companies to do
those things that are good for society.
Rather than giving them perverse
incentives to do things that might
be bad for society.
That set of government rules,
laws, and institutions,
that's really what's crucial for
unleashing the amazingly productive and
innovative capacities of capitalism in
ways that are good for society as a whole.
[MUSIC]
I have a 13 year old daughter,
and I think she's entirely unimpressed.
So I think from her perspective,
I don't know anything about anything.
>> I think my daughter and
my parents would have the same reaction,
which is my wife is the real scientist and
I'm the social scientist.
>> [LAUGH]